live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth
do work
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Jade Washoe Ramsey
personality is my co-host today as we
take your questions about your life and
your money it's a free call some say the
advice is worth exactly what you pay for
it the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Chris starts this hour in Phoenix
hi Chris how are you
I'm good thank you for taking my call
pleasure to speak with both to you and I
I hope the advice is better than free
which I'm sure it will be so thank you
we'll see we'll see when we're done okay
so
so we are a new uh ramzanite or I'm not
sure if there's a correct term we're new
to the Ramsay plan started in January uh
we've paid off twenty seven thousand
four hundred fifteen dollars and fifty
eight cents the problem is that we keep
having
I've had some medical issues she just
got out of the hospital for two weeks
um just last week just found out my son
needs like three thousand dollars for a
car payment or a car uh repair and we
just feel like we're going one step
forward and two step back and we can't
just get traction and uh my question is
my grandmother gave us a stock when she
passed away
and it was worth about a hundred dollars
a share now it's worth about 240 so it
went from about 8 000 to 24 000. should
we sell that
should we do something else I just don't
know what to do
I do think that you should liquidate
that stock
um
are you going back when you say you're
going backwards are you like going
through your thousand dollar emergency
fund backwards starting from scratch or
is it just you're not making the type of
Headway on your snowball that you'd like
to make
I would say both
okay all right I agree with Jade the
thing the thing is this twenty four
thousand dollars cashed in an emergency
fund will not make the emergency stop
okay there are two kinds of what
happened with Sharon and I and see if
you can relate to this Jade if it worked
with you all too the more we planned
and the better we got at budgeting and
the more we save the fewer emergencies
we had yep because when you're not
budgeting for uh say car repairs
like cars aren't going to break of
course they're going to break so you're
going to be budgeting for car repairs if
you're budgeting for car repairs a car
repair comes up you just fix a car it's
not an emergency if you have a chronic
medical situation an ongoing medical
situation that becomes a budget item
that's something you're just setting
money aside every month for and it's not
an emergency and so the more money you
have and the better planning you are the
bigger a thing it takes for it to be an
emergency you're still in the early
stages where every little thing has
added drama
now hospitals hospital stays aren't
little things but car repair with your
son tell me about that one
was it now not a very expensive car that
we got from he's a junior and Junior and
what so high school okay
um and uh and so there was just some
issue there was some engine issues now
there's just that we got a cheap older
car and so uh the repairs are not the
car's worth more than the repairs right
um so that's good but it just it just
happened we just found out Friday and
again my wife got out of the hospital
last it was a bad week last week let's
put it that way okay there's two things
that help you with this emotionally one
is if you look at these things you go
okay your wife being in the hospital
unless is this a chronic illness what's
wrong with her
um she does have a chronic illness but
this was something totally different
that was an actual emergency and she had
to have a procedure and some things done
to get her better had nothing to do with
her other medical issue unfortunately
okay
and so you know that event is a one-off
yeah correct the chances of that
happening again in the next three years
are very close to zero
I would agree okay and so you know
you're not gonna have ten of those
but you will have 10 of the car breaking
down yeah foreign
those are predictable things that go on
I mean oh oh my dog got sick and had to
go to the vet if you have a dog you need
a lineup it's gonna be sick yep
you know it's the vets and if you have
children pediatrician bills are not an
emergency they're an expected thing
they're going to get the flu they're
going to bust their head and have to
have Staples just count on it hey are
you using an every dollar budget
I do have the every dollar app we did
start with that okay
in January when we said you had you
hadn't factored in these other life
things yet I didn't say I was doing it
well Dave I wasn't making fun of you
you're in a very
if you need to be smacked around I'll do
it you know I'm good at that that's
you're actually doing good for the stage
that you're in you've been doing this
for only about six or seven months and
you're at the stage where you discover
that I can plan away some emergencies
therefore they're not really emergencies
other emerging in my every dollar budget
other emergencies are going to be an
anomaly and they're always going to
happen and that's what the emergency
fund is for and when you do that every
dollar budget let's say you did your
budget for uh August right and we're
going into September it will use August
the the previous month's budget as a
template for the coming months budget
and you need to use that to learn from
you need to look at those things and go
okay you know what there was a medical
thing on there and maybe that was a
one-off but maybe that's an indicator
that I need to put some keep that on my
line item we had a car you know learn
from what your previous month line items
were because that's telling you about
what your life situation is don't just
take them off there and assume they're
one-offs learn from that and go okay you
know what let me let me go back because
a couple months ago we had something
like that too so that's an opportunity
for you to learn the longer you do it
the more accurate it becomes it sounds
silly but when we first start our budget
our kids were little and uh
a field trip yes that we didn't know
about and surprised us
an activity fee at school that we didn't
know became an emergency and that's the
type of thing I'm talking about that's
not really emergency and so I
transferred that emergency from me to
the kid by saying you don't tell us and
it's not in the budget you don't go
facts and suddenly they their memories
improve their ability to communicate
from the classroom to the home was
vastly improved that's right yeah you
put it so I just transferred so now it's
not an emergency now we can plan for it
we don't have to have all this drama
because emergencies always have drama
well yeah I mean it's it's a teenagers
car breaks that's a lot of drama
but if you look at it a lot of
a lot of it's like if you just look at
the context clues you might find that
it's coming and you need to prepare for
like if your AC it's it's barely making
it it's making noises you have to look
for the context clues that are going so
you say okay you know what well it's 10
years old and we have record heat right
count on it yes count on it it's coming
on it just count on it hey every dollar
budget webinar this Wednesday Jade is
going to be doing this uh talking about
irregular income talking about how to
prepare for upcoming emergencies that's
right uh gonna be covering all of it
it's a free webinar limited only ten
thousand folks can come and we've been
having a little bit over ten thousand
sign up for these so free every go to
everydollar.com budgeting it's this
Wednesday what time it is at lunchtime
11 30 Central Time central time all
right uh Jade's every dollar webinar
August 30th everydollar.com budgeting
completely free on how to run the every
dollar app and how to run a budget this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
it's a competitive home buying Market
but there's a way you can get an edge
Churchill Mortgage works with you to
understand your budget and your goals
and the Churchill Mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Churchill has
bumped up their seller guarantee to ten
thousand dollars giving your offer the
best chance of being accepted and
helping you win in today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
Jade wash all Ramsey personality is with
us today open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five I don't
know if we're allowed to announce this
or not but I'm going to act like I own
the place uh George Campbell is not here
today
because George has a new little girl
that's right Dave and uh she is
beautiful she looks just like her mother
thank God yes she does and uh she's
precious and she came on Friday and
um he's useless I bet he is he is
completely useless he's in a pile yeah
he's complete well that's what little
girls do let's do that to start with but
uh man I'm telling you George he is
going to be a um an enabling doting
father a 100 percent useless she is with
his dog so I know he will always be with
his kids the dogs the dogs might uh have
to take a lower list on the totem pole
the dogs have no idea how much their
life is getting ready to change
I know that's right oh it's exciting
well congratulations to George and
Whitney Little Mia is absolutely
cute cute well she's like he did post it
on the on his Instagram so I guess I can
say it on the right here it is it's not
a secret so yeah James yeah precious
little thing all right open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Jamie is with us in Alberta hi
Jamie welcome to Alberta Canada welcome
to the Ramsay show
hi thanks Dave for taking my call sure
what's up
um I just wanted to say uh my husband
and I started your baby step last
September so about a year now and
uh we did the whole beans and rice I
sold everything we had and I went back
to work we got completely debt free paid
off 40 000 in depth way to go fully
funded emergency fund and are now and
we've already been putting um our 15
away into retirement so now we're kind
of on step I guess five and six um but
we've kind of come to a bit of a
I don't know it feels like stagnant spot
now in this plan because my husband's
lost motivation because you know we
accomplished so much and he's not really
Keen to pay down the mortgage
um he thinks wait a minute a Canadian
that doesn't want to pay down their
mortgage do you know how weird that is
well I I guess yeah I I mean he wants to
but not at the expense of us not having
any fun for the next
20 years of our life well there is some
something to be said about that because
you're used to the intensity of baby
step one two and three right it's you're
just going hard in the paint every
dollar is going to that but it doesn't
have to be like that for baby step six
I know everybody he wants to live a
little get out of that he does and I
want to stay in this mentality because
no you're wrong
you're just kind of gluttonous and you
want things we don't need and no he's
like he just would like to eat
occasionally yeah he you've not been
feeding him he wants a new pair of jeans
okay
well it's not so much that it's bigger
stuff like he wants because right now if
he works in overtime shifts he brings in
about an extra
six hundred dollars just for one shift
so he works a couple of those a month he
wants all that extra money to go towards
a camper or like a piece of land for our
us and our kids to enjoy which I'm like
I want to do that but not until we have
like do you have the money to save up
for that piece of land and like aside
from the 600 that he's getting for this
overtime do you have other money to put
towards the mortgage oh yes no you
probably have every month we probably
have an extra
two thousand dollars that just kind of
isn't doing much you gotta let him have
the 600.
no no no no no no no not the 600. it may
be a thousand it may be 400. it's not
yeah his overtime is not relevant he's
not it's the here's what we don't do
okay we're gonna move after baby step
three from intense scorched Earth beans
and rice rice and beans ramen noodles
we're gonna move away from that in baby
steps four five and six from intense to
intentional intentional means these are
the stages at which you pay cash and
upgrade your car these are the stages
you save up and buy an inexpensive paid
for used camper not a three hundred
thousand dollar camper oh no okay this
is the stage at which we go on vacation
this is the stage at which we can put
going out to eat back in the budget this
is the stage if we need to replace the
20 year old mattress we pay cash for it
and replace the mattress this is
intentional not intense and some of
those things are going to slow down if
you had what you could have put towards
the house but you're gonna do some of
those things because it's a longer
schlog to pay off the house
you know you're moving from sprinting to
marathoning Jamie let me ask you a
question and my knowledge on this is
somewhat slim but I do know in Canada
your interest rate changes every several
years right like every five years
every 10 years is that right is it is
that what you're trying to avoid is
there any part of that
kind of yeah so we've just resigned for
five years of mortgage right before
rates went up so we're only paying 2.2
which is awesome no you just got your
you just got the pedal to the metal and
you don't want to let up she doesn't
exactly you are still going to pay off
your hand you're still gonna pay off
your mortgage so fast you will how much
is a balance on how much is a balance on
your mortgage
uh
what's your household income
um depend like about including the
overtime generally it's about
200 000 combined okay so when are you
think you're gonna pay off the house
like five years
well if it's my husband's way it won't
be for 15. no your husband's not really
saying 15 you're whining
it's not all or nothing honestly
honestly you could do it with intensity
you could do it in three and a half to
four years of course I agree
no no no no out but I am not going to
recommend that
okay I'm not going to recommend three
and a half to four I'm going to
recommend five or six and buy an
inexpensive camper I would not buy the
land I buy a nice camper I'd buy some
things around the house loosen up and
enjoy your life a little so it sounds
like if you are really telling the truth
about him I think you're exaggerating
his position but if you're really
telling the truth about him what we're
telling you to do is between you two but
I'm thinking he's probably closer to
where we are and you're just all riled
up she's all or
I love it that's what got you here of
course that's wonderful but it's not
sustainable over four years it's five
years it's very difficult to do that you
all did it over a long period of time
but you were in baby step two the whole
time yes and you don't have a choice
look Sam and I have had that
conversation and I am
like but I put a money on the house and
he's like calm down
Anna is with us in Meridian Mississippi
hi Anna how are you
I'm great thank you so excited to be
talking to you you too what's up
um okay I have a question about
retirement um if I can give you some
numbers my husband are about 56 years
old I get a 2 000 a month pension I do
some contract work that brings in about
2 000 a month he makes about 120 a year
he has 350 000 in his work 457 account
our house is worth about four hundred
thousand we owe 180.
because we are behind the game in
investing because obviously through the
years if we had done the 15 for years we
would have had more than 350 in his
account
should we invest more and just pay the
regular on the house make the regular
house payment or should we
pay try to pay down the house and
continue with just the 15 percent
investment
well the way that we're going to teach
you we're always going to tell you to
walk through our series of baby steps
how familiar are you with those baby
steps
I am I am familiar so we are doing the
15 nails that we haven't been yeah so I
didn't know if we needed are you going
to keep doing it going forward at least
15 absolutely as long as you keep as
long as you keep doing the 15 going
forward any money above that that you
have left you would throw out your
mortgage because you want to get that
mortgage paid off you owe 180 000 on it
he's making 120 000 a year it sounds
like you're also getting another piece
of income 2000 a month you've got a lot
you've got a big shovel to really hit
this thing yeah so you you got about 120
530 000 to hit this with I'm gonna do
exactly the baby steps here's why do you
want to paid for house when you get to
retirement here's the other thing is the
350 invested in good mutual funds
sure it's invested in good mutual funds
the way we teach and making a good
return if it's making 10 it'll double
every seven years so not counting what
you put in the 350 when you're 63 will
be 700. when you're 70 it'll be 1.4
million you're gonna be okay you're
gonna be okay if you keep on track
you're gonna be just fine this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
their
one guarantee and shipping is always
free see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
40 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today I'm Dave
Ramsey this is the Ramsey Show
so student loans are emerging from Deep
Freeze and borrowers are confused
The Wall Street Journal says I will add
to that
um they're angry oh yeah I will add to
that that they're scared yes
frustrated yeah it's a student loan
borrowers are finding out that
restarting 1.6 trillion Federal program
is much more confusing than just when
they're able to turn the switch off
right it's harder to turn it back on
with the pandemic relief ending
borrowers will start owing interest as
of Friday as in in four days they are
learning new payment schedules they're
often getting this information via email
from these servicers that they might not
have ever heard of okay
and this is what I want to talk about I
know you guys are getting
emails in and it's like oh who are you
oh you're the person who's cervix in my
loan now and you don't even know you
don't even know what your payment is it
says it's this is about four in ten
borrowers their loan was transferred to
a new servicer during the pause that
began March 20 2020. 40 percent
they moved the servicing on an already
incompetent and in-apped Industry yeah
this is going to be a freaking
barrel of Fish Hooks
little new servicers I mean you got 40
million people
so 40 is 16 million
16 million accounts have been moved and
are all restarting interest Friday and
payments in October
and only the government can create a
mess like this you mean you have to work
to screw up Christmas seriously look
and the problem is these people are
calling to find out information this one
lady her story is she's had her loans
forever she's got 14 000 left and she's
calling and not able to get through the
lines because the lines are so jammed
and she can't get clarification on what
her loan is on what the amount is and so
after three years of payment she's
finally called of no payment she's
finally called and can't get answers so
that's what we've been telling you guys
don't wait on this don't sit on your
hands don't wait till last minute you
need to here's what's going to happen if
you do nothing because you get confused
because you can't get through on the
lines they're going to tag you with late
fees
at least you're not paying your payment
on time even though you don't even know
where they are
yeah they're gonna you're gonna get
confused because there's a couple of
things there's different options out
there right they've got these payment
plans that they're automatically
enrolling some people in and they will
automatically enroll you if you are
delinquent on your first few payments so
you do not want to just act like this is
not happening right now it's time to be
in denial now they'll put you in the 30
year you're never going to pay it off
plan
automatically that's the default plan
yeah 30 years you're never going to pay
it off that's like a mortgage You're
Gonna Keep forever that's the idea the
other default is that it's it's like
they're calling it an on-ramp Dave where
it's I need a 12 month on-ramp during
which time by the way interest is
accumulating but they're telling you
okay that's fine we just won't report
you don't credit you yeah we just won't
report it you're still screwing yourself
we just won't tell anybody we're gonna
screw you but we're going to ease you
into it so let me help you with this
okay A Bank
that has a loan out
with you
if they are collecting the interest does
not want you to pay off the loan
they want to collect the interest
forever you know what a student loan
servicer is
a bank
you know when they want you to pay off
the student loan
never
they just want you to pay fees and
interest
forever so they're going to make this
difficult and confusing and frustrating
because they want you there
forever and they're going to offer you
plans that are forever
this is how this works boys and girls
don't be naive this is this is called
Planned incompetence
the navient a the navient agent on
borrowed future said that they were
trained to mess up the call so you would
hang up and get frustrated and not get
your situation rectified so you stayed
in debt
forever that's in our documentary on
student loans a an actual agent that
used to be on the phones with navient
and uh we we had to garble her voice
because she feared for her life because
you know you don't cross these people
I'm kidding but not really but um oh my
gosh well here's what ever what I want
you guys to take away from this is a
we're here to give you information and
we're going to tell you more about a
live stream that we're going to offer
about this very thing but y'all are
smart you can go online you can read
about this stuff you can find out for
yourself you can be in the know so that
when you talk to these people on the
phone they're not you're not relying on
them for information you already know
what you want to do and you're going to
do what you're going to do that does
that make sense don't call these people
saying well what do you think I should
do do you think I should get on a
payment plan and forget my lounge honey
that ship has sailed they are not your
advisors yeah we're talking about the uh
the Supreme Court shot a cannonball
through his butt okay there is no
forgiveness no we're done he sunk the
ship it's done the ship has sailed it's
gone yeah you're not getting forgiveness
the forgiveness is going to come at the
tips of your fingers when you push
submit payments submit payment submit
payment over and over and over and you
pay the freaking thing off that's where
forgiveness is going to come from so I
you don't need to ask anybody about that
that's already pretty much old news it
was called a it was called a suspect a
sus move politically when he when he
said the Forgiveness anyway he's a
lawyer he knew an executive order didn't
have the ability to do something that
the act of Congress is required and the
Supreme Court confirmed it for him it
was sus from beginning it helped him
with the midterm elections guys grow up
pay off your freaking debts those of you
that have had ahead in the sand let me
tell you about this this stuff has a
high rate of Resurrection it will come
up out of the graves zombie fire your
butt okay it will come up and walk dead
straight into your living room deal with
this that's a fact I told people I was
sharing with them a couple of days back
on the show you know Sam and I had 280
000 of student loans different providers
they got sold off and were spread into
chunks everywhere did you experience the
planned and competence oh yeah uh look
if you that's why I said if you get on
the phone with these people these are
their parents are first yes they hire
people whose parents are cousins the
worst yeah kissing cousins the worst of
the worst okay you can't depend on them
they will keep you in debt forever
you're inbred brain damaged fool get my
account straightened out oh my God yeah
it's unbelievable all they want is a
payment all they want is a payment they
don't want your piece and we actually
they don't even really want a payment
they just want the interest and the fees
they want you to stay in debt for ever
did I mention that forever there we go
so we're going to help you with this
Wall Street journals telling you that
people are really confused we've added
to that we know some of you are angry
and we know some of you are scared
you're disillusioned with the political
system oh welcome to adulthood and so uh
yeah there you go you're gonna end up
paying this boys and girls men and women
gentlemen ladies you're going to pay it
so let us help you we're going to do
that we're gonna Jade who knows
something about paying this off paid off
260 000 bucks Rachel Cruz leading
student loan expert Financial uh expert
with Ramsey and I'm going to hang around
too the three of us are going to do a
student loan live stream we're excited
about this it's going to be incredible
it's how we got into this mess and how
we're going to get out student loan debt
in America we're doing this on September
the 12th you know how much we're going
to charge you nothing it's free for free
and let me just reiterate it's worth
every penny this is we're going to give
you real solutions we're going to show
you tactful things
that's what we do we're best Solutions
look at that look at that we're going to
help you guys yeah seriously we're going
to show you uh how to get out but
uh you know
spoiler alert
no easy way there's work involved yeah
this is not alert you're gonna pay a
price to win spoiler alert we don't have
any hacks that make this easy spoiler
alert all we're going to do is do our
best to give you information and
inspiration to get your butt in gear
because some of you have been sitting
around your head in the sand and it's
not going to get any better you know
what happens when you stick your head in
the sand your butt is exposed okay it
doesn't work all right you've got to
deal with this you got to deal with it
student loan live stream
ramseysolutions.com student loans sign
up it's September the 12th it's
completely free and uh we want you to
watch it because we're going to a lot of
trouble to do it and we don't want two
people watching this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with why
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump sum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
personality is my co-host today open
phone's a Triple Eight
two five five two two five Teresa's in
Orlando hi Theresa how are you
hi Dave I'm great thank you long time
listener for sun caller absolutely
honored to have you how can we help
awesome
um so
um we my husband and I we are looking
for a piece of land to build a home on
we're looking for like two to five acres
and we're just now getting started on
this this journey in this process
um
I don't even really know exactly where
to begin I have actually
um already started talking with
Churchill Mortgage and a broker's been
um working with me so far
um I just want to know you know what
kind of wisdom you would share of uh
buying land and building a house we are
debt free and we have 90 000 to put down
an aspect of this is my husband really
wants to use his VA loan
um he he wants to use the VA process is
he disabled
uh he's he's not disabled but he is
medically retired from
um from the military
um and he works full-time and I do too
we're both in public service sector yeah
if you are if you're if you're disabled
according to the VA then they will waive
the VA fees otherwise you don't want to
use the VA and I'm not positive if what
you've just described is going to
qualify the VA is the most expensive
loan out there
it's not a good loan unless you're
disabled now medically discharged may
qualify him for the waiver of all those
fees if it does then it's fine to use it
okay I think that it does
um and so Churchill can tell you based
on your Churchill can tell you based on
the uh the application you put in and
based on the type of medical payments
you're receiving from the military but
um okay you have to be uh disabled
according to the military it sounds like
he is it sounds like that's what you're
describing but um yeah but if you're uh
just a a non-disabled veteran do not use
the VA because it is more expensive
okay which is weird because it's
supposed to be a veterans benefit and
then it's more expensive so that's dumb
but that's doesn't matter it's the
government so right okay so it really
comes down to this to the fees
um another question that I had for you
was um so we have 90 000 to to put down
towards this journey
um should we
um so I have a 401k and you know I
contribute
um to the match that my company matches
and then my husband
um does deferred comp
um because she's with the sheriff's
department should we pause those
Investments while we stack up cash
um since it's a land and building loan
they want like a lot more money down
you don't have to
um it depends on how quickly you want to
accomplish this goal
right like if you if if it's important
to you to get into the house now and get
you know get this money stacked up as
quickly as possible you could pause it
the maximum I'd be putting into
retirement is 15 of your income
yeah if you're putting in more than that
I would back it down at least to that if
you want to back it down a little bit
more temporarily but what are you
thinking you're going to spend on the
land on the build
so it's not it's not easy in the area
that we
um and that we're in it's not easy in
any area yeah so
um the land it's looking like it's going
to be about 200 to 250 000
um and then I've been quoted by Builders
um of the type house that we want to
build at about 250 000 also how much
land are you buying
two to five acres hopefully five acres
that ratio is not smart
okay typically uh you're buying it
you're buying a state lot at the most
but um you know typically if you're
doing a typical lot build your your land
cost should be 20 of your total project
and so you're you're a little steep
there you're a 50
um and you're not buying 100 acres if
you're buying 100 acres of ratios change
okay but
um you know I you may be under building
that area substantially
um I don't know I mean you need to think
about where you're buying this land in
ratio to the size of the project but if
you got 90 grand down on a 400 if you've
got a 400 000 500 000 project and you
got 90 grand down you got a bankable
deal right now you don't have to have 50
down to get a construction loan you're
by because a construction loan is going
to take a loan a lien against the
property a first position meaning
they're not gonna not gonna be a land
loan and a construction loan they're
take out the land loan because and then
they will do draws to the Builder build
raising the amount of debt as it goes as
the house is built because the money's
being paid out to the lumber company the
money's being paid out to the uh
different subcontractors as the build
goes
and then when the total house is done
you've got a set Loan in your case it's
going to be 300 350 000 or so and then
that's going to be with Churchill
Mortgage become you're going to roll
that into a regular mortgage a
traditional mortgage a permanent
mortgage and you have to get a letter
that states that you have that regular
mortgage lined up in order to get the
construction loan and that letter is
called a takeout letter
and the takeout letter means the new
permanent mortgage is going to take out
the construction loan after the house is
completed that's what it means and so
you got to get all that lined up and
then push those dominoes and you can
close on the land you can close on you
don't you know you can close on the
construction loan you can get the
Builder started all the same week once
you've got everything lined up but get
your plans done the budget's done
um
the Builder selected uh and get
everything lined up and then you know
fire a pistol and push the dominoes
everybody go here we go love it
otherwise otherwise it drags out forever
you end up spending three years building
a stinking house yeah Mike my biggest
thing for her was like you said the the
land is costing equal to the amount of
the home it doesn't feel it's okay I
mean that would be okay if again if
you've got a large tract but I guess my
question is does that affect how they
are funneling those funds to the
construction loan if the ratio is not
right
no they're still going to make a I mean
uh
they still want to see the equity in the
house when it's done so if she's got a
total land and build of 350 000 in the
thing and it's worth 500. they're still
going to be fine that's true okay
they're still looking for that loan to
value ratio at the end of the project
regardless of how we got there in their
case it's just a small house on a big
piece of ground okay so that that's
really just for her
her value exactly exactly that's the
thing because again you take a million
dollar house is typically a 200 000 lot
that makes sense you know you gotta back
in a hundred years ago it's a hundred
thousand dollar house twenty thousand
dollar lot yeah five hundred thousand
dollar house you know you're looking at
uh a hundred thousand dollar a lot so I
mean that's just you know twenty percent
it's our general rule of thumb it's not
exact it's not a you broke something or
you did something wrong it's not dumb
but that's just a general rule on a lot
but if you put 100 acres under it you
might have 75 percent in the land and 25
in the house that's true I just wonder
well that's neither here or there I
could
come up with stuff on that all day I'm
thinking if she under builds that house
on that plot of land could that cause
her issues selling it down the line yes
well and it it's because it's weird it's
in a weird it's an under it's a house
that's the smallest thing in the
neighborhood very very strange I'd
rather be the smallest than the largest
but it's still it's still a problem so
that's what you're looking for and you
know let's just go in the sidebar just a
second a lot of people talking about
building right now it's a great time to
build by the way I'm building a house
right now it's a great time to build
because building has slowed down with
the higher interest rates the markets
slowed down and uh there's more Builders
available more subs available the supply
chain crap from the uh from the fauci
quarantine has gone away and the uh you
know if so lumber prices are stabilized
sub prices are stabilized most things
have come back down to a normal
reasonable pricing structure on your
supplies you can get windows again uh
you know that kind of stuff so I'm in
the middle of a build project right this
second and I started at perfect timing
because everybody everybody's ready to
help so here's a couple things you want
to do when you're building all right
three pieces of paper run the project
that's how you do project management
people all right you have a budget
and we don't buy stuff over budget
so we got this much allocated for carpet
that's the carpet our Hardwoods that's
the that's what it is you got a plan
blueprint you build a house on paper
it's a lot cheaper to build it on paper
and change it on paper before you start
building and you have a schedule
are we on schedule are we on budget and
are we on plan and this is the
discussion my Builder and I have every
week
and we're all smiling because we're on
budget we're on schedule and we're on
plan
this is how it works this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jay if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramsesolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Jade wash
all Ramsay personality is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five Stewart is in
Richmond Virginia hi Stuart welcome to
the Ramsay show
hey Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up
great so my wife and I have some extra
money and we're trying to figure out the
best way to prioritize spending it to
give you a little bit of background
we're currently on baby steps four five
and six we're actually on baby steps
five and six for this year we've
finished uh funding for retirement
um this money that we have was initially
going to be earmarked for our kids
college because we just got to Baby
Steps five four five and six this year
so their funding is is low we've been
trying to step that up monthly and we're
putting away a pretty decent amount each
month but how old are they
so I have five kids and they range in
age from the eldest being 13 the
youngest being two okay
um we're currently putting away about
four thousand dollars a month uh in
their college savings
um I had two wrinkles come up
financially here this month one of which
was I got into a car accident cars
probably totaled it's gonna need to get
a new car at the same time
um the company that I work for has
offered me the opportunity to purchase
some Equity I already have a decent
amount it's I work for a privately held
company so it's illiquid but the money
that I put in there previously has
performed very very well so I wanted
to to purchase this if I if it made
sense it's about forty five thousand
dollars uh that we're we're working with
here and really just trying to figure
out the best way to allocate that
spending
your car had insurance on it didn't it
say car works yeah it wasn't all that
much uh probably eight or nine thousand
dollars uh actually you're driving an
eight or nine thousand dollar car the
totaling of the car is not the problem
because you can just go buy an eight or
nine thousand dollar car yeah I can buy
a new car correct okay the same car
probably about I mean that's what the
insurance is for
um the question is do you want to move
up in car
yeah most likely
correct and that my thought process
there is that we have uh like I said
five kids I was just driving a sedan I'm
most likely going to get you need to get
something a little bit bigger and um you
know softly used four or five-year-old
SUVs are still going for twenty five
thousand dollars or so uh in our area
no so the question is do you want to
move up in car
or buy equity in the thing because your
other car was fine until you had a wreck
right yeah so most likely we'll we'll
move up in car okay um that's fine
what's your household income
uh so I make about 280
um my wife is she says I'm with our kids
but she does some Bookkeeping on the
side it makes about 35. well if you if
you pay cash for a car that's worth 25
you make 250 there's nothing wrong with
that
would you prioritize putting some of
that into our kids college fund because
like I said we just started doing that
this year so it's pretty cool I'd rather
have a college fund than I would a
minority interest in a privately held
illiquid company yeah
okay okay for sure all right well yeah
that makes sense the the reason I was
thinking that is because I mean I've got
close to two hundred thousand dollars in
equity uh in the company and it's only
says performed pretty well yeah what's
your percentage of ownership
uh very very small yeah so it's a big
company yeah you got absolutely no
control of the situation
correct Bozo's running that could do
cocaine run the thing in the into a sink
right
yeah yeah that's a minority interest in
a privately Hill company it'll liquid
you're screw yeah I'd rather put the
extra money to the kids college fund or
paying off your own house yep
that's what I would yeah
yeah you got enough invested in this
okay okay yeah you got plenty of
investors are they going to take it
public or are you just going to sit here
and ride it out for the ROI
I I don't know the answer to that
question what's the extra strategy if
you quit
um it's I would be able to pull that out
at the next Equity event which is either
a recapitalization or a sales company
yeah okay
which is again at their whim at their
whim so you're stuck with it okay
yeah yeah this is yeah this is what
scares me about minority interest in in
small small you know it's not that small
but privately held situation where you
basically have zero control over this
that's what scares me and so yeah I'm
uh I think you got more than enough in
there I wouldn't put any more in it I'd
ride what you got and let's pay cash for
the kids college get your car and um I'm
throwing the rest and you know towards
the house like Jade said yeah going back
to what he said because I'm interested
if he if he did that what's the what's
the hope is that this company becomes
publicly traded no I mean is there they
have they've given him no indication
based on our conversation just now
they're going to do that yeah but that
would be the only basically his hope is
is that they make a profit and his
percentage he gets paid out in profits
and so he's the 200 000 he's got
invested today has made him good money
he's made a good rate of return on that
so say he's getting an extra fifty
thousand dollars a year I mean that's 25
red return that probably be about what
he's getting he's probably getting some
something north of 20. anyway uh today
but again
you know there's human beings running
the thing yeah and um and there's
variables in the economy you don't know
when the next voucher is going to come
along and so you just can't you just
can't control everything you know you
can't control everything outside of
yourself fauci really messed you up Dave
no no fouchy really messed up America
and so that means that for the rest of
my life I have the pleasure of messing
with fauci
yeah I love it when you turn when you
screw everybody and your name gets
turned into a verb
you got falchied that's when you know
you're you have been labeled permanently
so yeah
that's a psychological scar on all of us
and that's but it's okay we'll be okay
so can fauci get ramsied
I doubt he cares
probably probably not a big probably not
a big on his threat radar is probably
not a big thing
so I think he's probably a lot more
worried about Rand Paul open phone's a
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you guys jump in we'll talk about
your life and your money it's what we're
here for and we'll try to help you we're
an expert on our opinion that's right
and uh Hey we've helped a lot of folk
and um some people agree with it some
don't you don't have to do it you're
grown-ups you get to do what you want to
do but we'll teach you what we know and
what we've LED uh tens of millions of
people out of debt and millions of
people in the million dollar net worths
and uh more than anybody else and so we
got a pretty good track record but
there's a lot of reason to disagree with
us and I sometimes argue with myself so
I was doing that a while ago in a board
meeting we had our operating board
meeting this morning and I got an
argument with myself it's ridiculous as
long as you do it in front of people I
do but it's a little bit like I've got
multiple personalities oh wait I do I
have Jade and Rachel and George
that's good and baloney and Coleman and
there you go there you go lots of Ramsay
personalities this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace hallow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
personalities my co-host the Ramsey Show
question of the day sponsored by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
most American homes have dozens of Apple
of appliances and chances are at any
given time there's something wrong with
at least one of them Mr Appliance a
neighborly brand offers expert appliance
service on your schedule visit
neighborly.com to find out Home Service
Experts near you including a Mr
Appliance in your area today's question
comes from Cindy in Kansas she says we
have about 185 thousand dollars of
equity in our house with rates being
what they are right now is there
anything we can do with the with our
Equity or should we wait till rates drop
to possibly take out money to finish the
basement and redo the deck we have great
credit you know 115 000 on the house we
just don't understand if there's any
benefit to having all this Equity we do
plan to move in the next two years due
to better schools we're pulling out
would pulling from the equity of our
house to finish the basement to increase
our square footage to 3 000 square feet
be smart I got an offer from the bank
saying I could take out an interest-only
payment for 10 years but I never heard
of that before and I didn't know if it's
a good thing
um
we're from the bank and we're here to
help yeah those words don't go together
and if they do their lies they're not
here to help
um I want to make sure we're speaking
the same language here because
words like debt and loans and interest
rates I don't care a whole lot about
that what I do care about is this equity
in your home and the great thing about
that Equity Cindy is that's of value to
you that's wealth that you're building
in your home and no I would not take
that out to do repairs you're stealing
and robbing from your future when you do
that what I would do is start putting
aside money to do those repairs on your
home yourself and pay cash for those and
you might be thinking yeah Jade but I'm
going to move in two years and you know
won't I get the money back
maybe maybe not but I'd rather have that
money in equity so that when I go to
move you're getting all that money back
to put on your next home if you take all
that money now you're not going to have
much of a down payment to roll over into
the next home does that make sense so no
I would not pull out all of that Equity
as a matter of fact depending on what
your situation is if you don't have any
debt I'd actually double down and start
paying more to pay off the home or like
you said you could put some of that
money aside to save for the renovations
I would not deal with the bank on this I
would not go into debt for this
um not doing it that's all I can say
so um Cindy for though for you and those
like you that say um I never heard of
that before an interest-only loan
payment for 10 years oh interest only
means you paid only in the interest
which means you paid nothing on the debt
which means this goes on forever
and ever amen not only 10 years forever
and ever I'm in it just keeps going and
going and going going there's no end to
it none whatsoever just goes on you're
going to be in debt forever and the the
big problem with that is that you write
checks every month for the privilege of
going nowhere
just running like a rat in a wheel
that's what interest only is no traction
no progress and we know from having
studied wealthy people that one of the
primary things people do there's two
things that really cause people to get
their first one million to five million
dollars in net worth the two primary
things are they invest steadily in their
retirement plans and good growth stock
mutual funds like 401ks and Roth Irish
and they pay off their home
not pay only the interest and stand at
forever and ever and ever and ever so
the product that the bank is offering
you here is to screw you which is what
banks do
and they're there to mess you over
that's their job and they're good at it
and there's to take interest from you
and keep you in debt perpetually so
people that do this type of loan are
what we call middle class
perpetually
there's nothing evil about being middle
class but when you do middle class
stupid things they cause you to stay
middle class when you have the ability
to be much higher in the socio-economic
strata meaning you had millions of
dollars in net worth and you had a great
solid wonderful golden rocking chair at
your retirement instead of I hope the
government will take care of me
which is well known for its ability to
handle money this is a stupid plan okay
so no we don't do that
so the the deal is uh you know there's
here's some things that uh
you know we could just take a second and
talk about this it's a good idea because
I I grew up in a uh slightly lower
middle class family okay and so I
watched people do middle class stuff
okay here's what middle class by the way
there's poor people stuff that they do
too sure and then there's rich people
stuff that you do yes and it's not that
one's a person is better by character
than another by doing these things these
are just the financial moves that cause
you to stay in one of these areas okay
poor people would be payday lender yes
pawn shop
Title Loans
pay at the pay uh uh payday payday loan
like pay at the car lot whatever it is
um
rent to own your freaking washer and
dryer yeah and pay about 5x for it when
you do that uh these are Poor People's
Lottery lottery is going to make money
by the way almost all lottery tickets 78
lottery tickets are sold in poor zip
codes
yeah and and Tennessee the lottery
money's used to send uh middle class and
upper class people's kids to school they
pay for your they give you three
thousand four thousand dollars for
tuition so in Tennessee poor people are
sitting rich in middle class people's
kids to college so isn't that a
wonderful program I just love it it's
awesome and so this is what so that's
poor people stuff okay middle class
people stuff is car payments car payment
I'm gonna get rich on uh airline miles
with my credit card he locks he locks
I'm gonna I'm gonna take a second
mortgage out interest only and fix up my
basement and build a deck uh because I
deserve it I believe all the sofa
commercials the pretty people student
loans student loans middle class uh some
lower class but mainly middle class keep
your middle class for
um whole life life insurance
that's a good one yes uh leasing a car
yes very middle class very middle class
so rich people don't ask how much down
and how much a month
they ask how much
they avoid payments they pay for it or
they don't buy it and that's what got
them to be rich and it's what keeps them
rich
and so the rich get richer and the poor
get poorer yep because you keep doing
the same crap that causes it in both
cases
and so you keep doing rich people stuff
you get to be rich people I'm telling
you you make Thirty forty thousand fifty
thousand dollars a year in America today
and you do rich people stuff for the
next decade you will not be you will not
be poor anymore no you'll be all right
you just do the stuff they do you pay
cash for things you buy used cars uh you
don't lease stuff you don't Finance your
freaking vacations yes you stay out of
the timeshare office you run the whole
life agent out with a stick out of your
living room get out get out get
you know you do this is what you do
right you do you start doing this stuff
I mean and it's not a it's again it's
not a character thing yeah because it
was a character thing I would not have
anything absolutely because I mean I I'm
so dumb I had to become a millionaire
twice I lost it all the first time
because I did stupid butt stuff so it's
not it's not that but here's figure out
and you know there's even stuff that
people do by age group okay number one
mistake people do when they graduate
from college student loans no they
already have that
and I have to get a big girl car payment
to go with my big girl job because I I'm
embarrassed to drive the college car
uh-huh
God help you what a one percent problem
is that you had a college car
these are things that most people never
even dream of having in one sentence I
know this and you had that regardless of
if it was a hoopty but I had to go get a
35 000 car because the one I had didn't
have an airbag oh you're killing me here
yeah
yeah so this is ding ding ding ding
there's age group mistakes there's
social stratum mistakes and or behaviors
that cause you to be in that social
strata so if you want to level up
you change your behaviors that's right
you change your habits you change your
views where there is no vision the
people perish
that's like die
the vision is key and that is I want to
level up I'm going to do stuff I've
never done before so I have things I
never had before I'm gonna pay a price
to win I'm not going to follow all the
freaking all my broke friends I got an
opinion about money go do what your
broke friends do and see if you don't
look like one of your broke friends
that's pretty dumb this is the Ramsey
Show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34
thousand customers who trust netsuite to
help make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
[Applause]
Jade wash all Ramsay personality is my
co-host today Stacy is with us in Los
Angeles hi Stacy welcome to the Ramsay
show hey Dick hey so let me get right to
the point my wife and I were both 44
we're on baby step seven got a paid off
million dollar house have 1.2 million in
401ks ding ding well done
thank you oh Dave I have to tell you we
when we paid off the house this year I
took a picture of myself Barefoot on the
on the on the lawn and I posted on the
the baby step Millionaire's Facebook
page and I was overwhelmed with hundreds
and hundreds of people liking it and
commenting it you were absolutely right
it it just feels so different that's
great I love it
here I am between my wife and I were
making 200 Grand a year and we're just
piling up cash because we're Savers and
I've got 13 grandkids the youngest is
four weeks old the oldest is 13 and I'm
thinking how can I how can I be
intentional and give and help change
their lives and I'm thinking what's the
best way to save for their college or to
help pay for some of their college I
Googled 529s and and almost I got a
little confused and do I set up 13 529
so I said one 529 and then just allocate
as I see fit or what you know what or do
I just say the heck with it and just
keep just pull out of my investment
accounts when they turn 19 and go to
college I missed a misunderstood I must
have misunderstood you I thought you
said you were 44. that's what I thought
I am you're 44 with 13 grandkids I'm
sorry I'm sorry 54. 54. I'm sorry not
44. I'm feeling so much better me too
for everybody I mean we're all from
California not from Tennessee so I
couldn't figure that out okay my wife
always ran my wife always rounds up and
calls me 55 and I and in my mind I was
thinking four or four make sure you stay
okay that's okay I'm trying to make you
older I just thought your child bride or
something I didn't know what your deal
was right now all right all right so uh
here's what I would do if I were in your
shoes okay thank you if you put a 520 if
you put it into a 529 they need to be
individual
and uh they're then in the kid's name
and you can set yourself as the
custodian you're in total control of it
as the custodian
okay you don't even have to distribute
it to them you can just take the money
but the problem is you don't have to
distribute it to them until they do what
you say uh the problem is that uh that
money then has to be used for education
I probably
I mean I we we've uh thrown money in our
kids our grandbabies 529s on their first
birthday to get them started it's like a
tradition their parents don't need the
money but we do it just to help them
start the very first one right and to
get it going
um
and I've only got seven but uh but
anyway you've got the money so
we don't know the path the kid is going
to take
and when you're a grandparent you have
absolutely no control over the path the
kid is going to take and the money is
now in the kid's name when you put it in
a 529.
so I'm probably going to be more of a
control freak than that
well now you that's my nature and so my
thought was to just do one big like
separate fund yeah and then and then be
the you know the grandma grandpa
scholarship fund and there you go to
school and here's how you qualify okay
here's the qualifications for the
scholarship fund yeah we're not doing
drugs we're walking with Jesus you know
we're not uh you know uh
we're not a porn star you know whatever
it is right I mean you know you got
you're going to be living a clean life
right and so because otherwise you don't
qualify for the grandma and grandpa
scholarship fund and that's gives them
an incentive to um to stand tall and to
be somebody
so would you still do the 529 no I think
I just have a big fund and and I'd go
ahead and announce it to the parents and
the grandparents and I'd kind of start
talking about it like at Christmas
you know there's Grandpa scholarship
fund and
you know here's how you qualify and um
you know Mike Rowe would be proud if you
put a work ethic thing in there right
well did I tell you what the serving
Jesus is number one on the list that's
for sure yeah and um well here's the
thing I mean you're doing cocaine I'm
not going to fund your life because I
love you I don't want to kill you
and given a cocaine addict money ensures
they're going to die
so that's not an act of love that's just
an act of irresponsibility so yeah
that's that you know so you're gonna
that's why I'm controlling because I
love you I'm going to control These
funds because fun money makes these kids
and every one of us more of what we
already are
if you're a jerk and you get money
you're a colossal jerk
you know if you're misbehaving and you
get money you misbehave in style would
you tell them would you tell them how
much
is at stake
thank you that was my question how much
how old are they
so the youngest is three weeks and the
oldest is 13. and so my my goal is to
work backwards with a goal of 25 Grand
per per grandkid and then just what do I
need to invest monthly yearly so that
that's cool obviously obviously the
oldest because I have zero in the fun
today so obviously the oldest is going
to take you know the Lion's Share in
five years yeah but then you know I
might yeah I might pay two I might pay
tuition for four years to a state school
maximum of x
I like that today that'd be 40 Grand but
yeah
well I mean I'm not posted 40 yet time
and I got time and resources to get
there yeah just you do whatever you want
to do or I'll pay for the first two
years of tuition maximum of X but yeah I
think you're right but but let's let
them know because you got to put a limit
on it otherwise the you know we don't
know what the stupid colleges are gonna
do it could be 80 grand a year by the
time one of them gets there or something
and I don't want to be on the hook for
that so uh you know maximum of X
whatever X is and um I'll pay up to four
years of tuition uh to a state school
maximum of X and here's the five things
you do to qualify for the grandpa and
grandma scholarship I love this I love
this too good good job grandpa I love
this and here's the thing you know
here's the thing about this you're a
control freak no I just told you what
you could do
you get to choose I know that's right
that's good you get to church I know how
he's gonna answer this next question but
I'm going to ask it anyway so what
happens when when grandkid one gets you
know 35 Grand and then grandkid 2 gets
to zero because of the poor life choices
and and and they're you know when they
go crying to their other siblings or
they go crying to their parents tough
turkey toenails
we used to say tough turkey toenails
that's what we used to say because it's
your it's what they've said you I think
that's why you lay it out there ahead of
time it's not a surprise boundary
this is the qualifications for the
scholarship fund okay like I had a
friend who was Cherokee he's half
Cherokee and he got his entire college
paid for because he qualified for a
Native American whatever right
right I don't qualify for that
so I don't get to whine about it
because it's I'm not half Cherokee yeah
so shut your butt up you know call the
wambulance
you know and so you here's the deal and
your behavior you do get to call you get
to church
my DNA that's the way I can choose my
behaviors and my character those are
choices Integrity is a choice yeah and
they'll never be able to say that
there's no sexual promiscuity is a
choice these things are choices and they
affect your life long term and old
people like me and wonderfully wonderful
Stacy Grandpa there know these things so
we're more actually more concerned boys
and girls about your habit patterns and
your life because they're greater
indicator of your success than your
education yeah
do you know how to tell the truth do you
know how to smile do you know how to
shake a man or woman's hand look them in
the eye uh do you have a little bit of
moxie can you Swagger just a little bit
but not too much
I mean can you can you work a whole day
like a whole day can you get a callous
on your hand you know how to do that
these are the things that will cause you
to become successful more than your
degrees I know people with more degrees
than a thermometer they can't find their
way out of a wet bag
you know so I mean that's the thing so
you this is what Stacy's talking about
this is important stuff y'all building
character is more important megmaker
will talk about this in strong Father
Strong daughters one of the best
parenting experts on the planet right
now and boy is she catching some hell
because she's telling the truth
man talk to people about parenting in
this crazy world
man oh man
well guys teach your kids character and
then get them an education that that's
what Stacy's lining up here yeah I I am
I don't have a grandpa on Grandma
scholarship fund I might want one now I
know that's a good idea I might like the
control that that would give me you
would like that you would like that Dave
dude the influence the influence that
that would give me this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host Richie Is With
Us in Phoenix Arizona hi Richie how are
you hey Dave how you doing better than I
deserve what's up
hey so real quick um I've got a mortgage
it is the only debt I have
it is about 260 000 left I owe on the
house
I bought the house at an interest rate
of 2.7 percent
I have 250 000 in the bank so my
question is do I pay off the mortgage
everyone's telling me that I could use
that money and invest it and get a
better return on it
because I have such a low interest rate
on the mortgage
everyone
is broke yeah yeah right
so you don't want to go with the they
said and I heard financial planning firm
okay you follow broke people's advice
you what would you expect to be other
than broke
yeah yeah so let me ask you this let's
turn it around sometimes a good way to
figure things out is to reverse engineer
them and see how they feel
what's your home worth
um it's probably in the 450s 500. and
what do you what do you make a year
me and my wife together bring home about
120 000 a year how old are you uh 30 way
to go you've done very well Richard
congratulations well thanks Dave
appreciate it okay let's pretend you're
living in a 450 000 paid for house and
you have no money in your checking
except just an emergency fund of three
to six months of expenses set aside over
in savings okay okay
and your house is paid for
mortgage rates come down
and you can borrow whatever you want to
borrow on this paid for house at 275.
you're sitting there in a paid for house
can you breathe that in for a second
would you go get a mortgage
and I can borrow again yeah let's just
say you the interest rates were 275.
he's saying would you borrow against you
if your house was paid for you're
sitting in a paid for house at 30 years
old it's 450 000 you make 120 000 a year
you got 30 000 in your checking account
would you go borrow 250
000 300 000 on this house on this paid
for house at 275.
all right no probably not what's the
difference yeah exactly okay the
difference is this let me help you
when you ask the question in Reverse
what we're doing here is we're
activating your heart
because for once you kind of got your
head around what I was saying for just a
second even though it was a hypothetical
situation we discussed taking a paid for
house and putting it in debt for just a
second your stomach dropped jumped into
your throat and your heart start beating
faster
okay because the way that question asks
is it activates the risk because your
heart and your stomach measure risk your
brain does math
and that's a metaphor of sorts but my
point is what your friends are not
recognizing is risk
and every we've done detailed research
and 100 of the foreclosures occur on a
home with a mortgage
right so there's always risk even if
it's 275 even if you have a steady job
making a great income there's always a
level of risk now in your case it's not
a horrendous level of risk that's why it
kind of becomes a theoretical discussion
like a hmm I wonder if I should really
do that I wonder if my broke friends are
right because you're not feeling the
risk but let me tell you if that thing
was up to your eyeballs and you could
barely breathe you would feel the risk
yeah yeah because mortgages all debt
equals risk more debt equals more risk
less debt equals less risk and that is
not calculated in the math that your
broke friends are using
and that's what our reverse scenario
does for you it makes your body feel the
risk because you really do feel it well
yeah you're weighing you're weighing
both sides of the equation accurately
before it was easy to just say oh you
don't need to pay off your house without
even taking a moment to think what that
would feel like and weigh that side of
it and then when you do that it puts it
into perspective which is now Dr John
deloney talks about and I've never heard
anybody talk about it quite like he is
but the research that's there the way
our body carries
stress we physically physiologically
store up trauma yes store up stress and
so when someone says this debt is
weighing me down yeah that's an actual
true statement yeah you know if you are
carrying a backpack full of bricks yeah
your body keeps the score is what he
says that's what he says and um he's
quoting a famous piece of research but
we store trauma we store risk we store
pain
physically in our bodies and when you
don't have that there's a release 100
percent
and that's what God's meant when he said
the borrower is slave
to the lender yeah slaves don't have
choices
you know it changes things and you can't
uh you can't fool your body into
thinking it's not there your body does
know yeah we were talking about this
with the student loans you know people
are saying uh you know but I can get a a
lower payment and kick the can down the
road as if your body doesn't feel it as
if you don't really know somewhere deep
down in your nowhere yeah that this is
stupid yes and that it's still there
yeah it didn't go away you know you know
we just swept it under the rug and you
know all we got is our lumpy rug yep you
know what I mean that's it uh Harry is
with us in Michigan hi Harry welcome to
the Ramsay show
hello hi Dave thanks for taking the call
sure what's up
my question is this is like a general
education call I don't have a home yet
but I'm I've been looking at different
kinds of insurance just to reload
insurance and one of them is home
warranty insurance
uh I guess it's supposed to pay for any
major home repairs right uh so extended
warranty on your home yeah
yeah
okay
um like it or not like it don't like it
if somebody gives it to you free I'll
take it but um but I don't buy
warranties here's why extended
warranties on anything cars especially
but appliances and electronics and homes
here's the general numbers on them okay
12 of what you pay so out of a thousand
dollars a hundred and twenty dollars
covers the actual probability the
statistical probability of the
occurrences on average you know take a
thousand people to take out this home
warranty on average across a thousand
people a hundred and twenty dollars per
person is what's going to be spent on
the things that it covers so at the
actual coverage is about 120 so that
leaves another eight hundred and eighty
dollars that goes to profit to marketing
and to commissions
so the reason the car dealers are so big
on selling you a three thousand dollar
four thousand dollar extended warranty
on your twenty thousand dollar car is
it's 88 profit and marketing and
commissions
it's only 12 percent of the actual
warranty coverage is that same thing's
true on your home what you pay for it on
average versus what it covers is about
120 per thousand
um that's something it's almost like
they knew they were going to make a
profit well that's why they offered it
Best Buy okay Best Buy actually has
great buys on flat screen televisions
they don't make hardly any money on
their flat screen televisions not a lot
of margin I bet I know why
two things what do you think I think
they know they're going to recoup it on
the warranties if they push the
warranties hard enough and 90 days
Shameless cash
they make all their money on the
financing and on the warranties the TVs
are just there to get you in the Trap
wow step up on the news I promise I
won't pull the rope and hang your butt
upside down you'll be having blood
rushed to your head wondering what
happened you just stepped in the News
That's graphic Dave sorry that's what it
is
so what is you'll be hanging upside down
waiting on
whatever death is coming to you but
there it is you know I could cause all
kinds of problems things things running
through my mind I don't need to say but
yeah
the um anyway
yeah I mean that's Best Buy you you
can't buy a freaking number two pencil
in Best Buy but what they don't offer to
finance it for you and put an extended
warranty on it you can't get out of the
cash register the cash people the cash
register people can barely make change
but they know how to fill out the
warranty stuff those warranties are
everywhere I bought a coffee maker on
Amazon and asked me did I want a
warranty
I bought a t-shirt on Amazon for eight
dollars and asked me if I wanted to take
it on three payments
[Music]
you can't make that crap up
wow if you can't afford your T-shirt you
might be a redneck I'm just saying oh my
God three payments three easy payments
on a t-shirt
[Music]
and what even that funny a saying after
that I was just totally disillusioned
this is the Ramsay show
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show we help people
build wealth
do work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships Jade wash all
Ramsay personality is my co-host today
open phones a triple eight eight two
five five two two five our thanks to the
PODS moving and storage folks sponsoring
the studio if you're thinking about
moving you need to check these guys out
it is an inexpensive way to move and you
get total control if you uh everything
doesn't work out right you can put your
stuff in storage because they just bring
the Pod drumpet out front you fill it up
they put it in storage it works really
good so appreciate those guys hanging
out with us and uh if you need some help
with your move they're the people to
talk to Ricardo is with us Ricardo is in
Oklahoma City hey Ricardo welcome to the
Ramsay show
good afternoon hey what's up thank you
for letting me be on your show
I had a question just general question
um I have uh my wife and I both more
Hurst has a student loan and we've been
paying off it's but since uh you know
color put a interest freeze on it I've
saved the money and I paid it to myself
and have saved it so now that they're
about to kick on I'm wondering if I
should pay that lump sun to the student
loan or to a car payment that I've been
paying uh both of them are about at the
same of what I owe about 5500
is the student loan broken in into any
pieces or they're it's just one loan for
fifty five hundred
it's one loan for 5500 how much is in
the savings account
about 34.
100 dollars
yes 3400 okay what's your household
income
um about 80. okay
is the car what's the car is exactly
5500 as well
no it's the it's a little bit lower it's
about 41. pay the car first and the
student loan is 55. keep a thousand
aside as your starter emergency fund
because you want that in case anything
you know you need a starter emergency
fund but then that would be called baby
step two but baby step one but baby step
two is paying off all of your debt in
order from smallest to largest
not it doesn't matter about interest
rate or anything like that so just
keeping it simple and following the plan
I think is going to help you so keep a
thousand aside you've got 2400 to throw
at
car
how much other money do you have saved
I'm sorry how much other money do you
have saved
uh in my 401k no other than 401k
oh then not not much just like a few
hundred bucks
okay
um
you guys 24 how old are you
uh 43 43.
yes
and you make 80 grand how long have you
been married
seven years okay all right
um
tell me how you feel about this
statement
you make too much money to be this broke
yeah
is that correct
yes yeah I mean you make 80 000 a year
you shouldn't have a five thousand
dollar problem
no okay so here's what here's what's
happening here's what's happening all
the money comes in at your house all the
money goes out there's no plan
the fact that you saved forty four
hundred dollars in your world after nine
years of being together at seven years
of being married is that's the first
step of discipline and organization you
guys have ever had congratulations
you're on the right track
I want you to take that little seed
right there and let's grow that into an
oak tree
I want you to save 34
000 now
you make too much money to be this broke
sloppy and disorganized and overspending
I know I used to do it I'm not picking
on you am I wrong right
no no
this needs to be
like Dave said this needs to be an I've
had a moment
when you've come this far you've been
married seven years you've got this debt
and you can't come up with five thousand
dollars or all you've got to your name
is thirty four hundred dollars that's a
lot of money going out the drain hey ten
years from today you'll be 52 right
right
okay and so what you got to ask yourself
is what kind of conversation the 52 year
old version of you is going to have with
the 42 year old version
of you are you gonna be pissed at him
you've been working your whole life you
got nothing
or you're gonna go man I'm so proud of
you that's the day you decided I'm gonna
put that 3 400 over that 4 400 towards
that car I'm Gonna Roll up my sleeves my
wife and I are gonna sit down tonight
we're gonna start talking grown-up talk
like live on less than you make we're
not freaking Congress
we're gonna get this thing under control
we're going to take an extra job we're
gonna sell so much stuff the kids think
they're next we're going to clear this
car we're gonna clear the student loan
we're gonna put emergency fund in place
we're going to start saving into our
four how much is in your 401k
uh
I want to say 35
000 I haven't checked it right and I
haven't checked it lately yeah is this
your hey is this your only debt I'm
curious
no I have more but this is the one I'm
trying to start with the I got the car
on the straight line what else
uh the mortgage oh okay okay where
you're at is a really dangerous place
yeah because you've got your income
feels like oh yeah I'm making enough
money it's really easy to wander into
debt and feel like it's not that big of
a deal you're not a guy that's got you
know forty thousand dollars a day eighty
thousand dollars a debt so you're not
feeling the weight in the same way it's
easy to just lollygag around and and and
spend money it's so frivolously and if
you don't stop you're gonna wake up and
be 60 have not not have enough
retirement have a car note have those
normal things that because it's not this
big massive weight of debt it's caused
you to not be
um intentional about getting ahead you
want cotton mouth it's the taste of
regret in the back of your tongue you
don't want that one
you don't get there already that guy so
that hey man I love you I'm proud of you
you've turned the corner here and we
want to help you go the next step if we
give you our nine week class Financial
Peace University would you and your wife
go through promise to go through it if I
give it to you free
yes okay yes I can all right and you
call us back if you got any more
questions we'll fuss at you some more
because we love you okay we're not mad
at you we just want you to win man
that's true and um I understand the
feelings that you got you are a lot of
America right now there's 44 million
Americans with student loans this the
interest starts back Friday
the payments start back one month later
and people are starting to go
holy crap
because um you know as good a job as
Ricardo did let's be straight about the
math okay
in the last three years
four thousand four hundred dollars would
have been a lot less than his payments
yeah so he saved some towards it which
is more than most people did yes but he
didn't even save the payments that's
right no no over four years so well he
might have on fifty five hundred
maybe he might have I might be wrong I
might I think that's wrong I think he
did I think he did but most people
hadn't that most people spent the money
and now they've got it coming at them
hey we're student loans in America how
we got here and how to get you out we're
going to help you with that it's a free
live stream September the 12th sign up
at
ramseysolutions.com
student loans free this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America Jennifer is
with us in Raleigh North Carolina hi
Jennifer welcome to the Ramsay show
hi thank you both for taking my call
sure what's up um
August I joined Jay's webinar on the 9th
about the every dollar app was that
helpful and yeah well she's sitting here
so you can tell the truth thank you
you're welcome I'm glad you were there
um on the 16th we had my husband and I
had our 21st wedding anniversary
and we decided to cut up our credit card
that we had been using for 21 years wow
yeah
um we also decided that we want to
attack our HELOC now we call it a HELOC
I know what some people say
but we came up with a new mantra we're
locked into hell I got it no we're
saying let's get the hellock out of here
hey come on now I love it
I'm going with this I need a t-shirt I'm
going with it good
[Applause]
long do you think it might take us to
pay off our HELOC
is there any other debt besides it
no okay what's your household income
231.5 and how much is your HELOC
much is your first
mortgage
oh is 487. okay
all right and so you're at baby step six
uh what's your interest rate on your
first
it is uh 2.875 on the mortgage and it is
at 8.75 right now on thank you on the
HELOC yeah ouch okay
um you're not going to reduce the
hellock a lot in this current
environment if you refinance them
together you would have a net loss on
the interest so we won't do that if you
were in baby step two I would tell you
to move the hellock to baby step six you
however are already in baby step six you
have an emergency fund you're putting 15
towards your uh retirement I assume if
not that's what we would tell you to do
and then we say okay make 231 how much
can we throw at a 222 thousand dollar
HELOC
yeah so
when I listen to your show and I just
needed some motivation I've been so
motivated by so many Dutch free screen
people but we
don't I'm like our emergency fund is a
thousand dollars and we have two
thousand dollars in checking right now
so okay you gotta get the emergency fund
built up before we have this discussion
once it's built up to three to six
months of expenses then you need to
start putting 15 into your 401k or you
guys already putting money in the 401K
we have 660 000 in the 401K are you
putting money in there this month out of
your paycheck yes it comes out off the
top okay how much what percentage of
your income is going into 401ks and Roth
IRAs
10. okay and we're going to raise that
up after we get the emergency fund in
place no you're going to do it so fast
with your income it doesn't matter all
right so let's just fast let's fast
forward two months you have an emergency
fund and you're starting to put 15 of
your income away that's our baby steps
baby step four then that's going to move
you on to the HELOC
um and if you put fifty thousand dollars
a year fifty five thousand dollars a
year towards it uh you will be debt free
in four years other than your first
mortgage
do you
do you not unless it's less than half
your annual income and it's not as equal
to your annual income did you have debt
before this HELOC
um
uh not really we had a car actually but
then we moved into this house in March
of 2020 and that's when we took on this
HELOC so um what a day to move I know
right yeah it was actually such a
blessing such a blessing yeah
let me ask you is there any part of you
this is this is this is Jade talking and
Dave can correct me if I'm wrong there's
part of me that because it's debt
secondary to my mortgage there's part of
me that would want to hit this with a
stronger intensity
then I would attack the first mortgage
once I knocked out the hellock then I
would
slide back into more of an
intentionality spot what do you think
Dave well I mean
I'm gonna be focused on but I'm not
gonna change the baby steps to do it
um I'm gonna put 15 of your income
towards the retirement and I'm going to
make sure you have an emergency fund and
then I still think you can put 55 000 a
year and be done in four years if you
want to crank it up a little bit heavier
than that and pay it off a little
quicker than four years that's fine or
if you guys get some bonuses or an
inheritance or anything you throw it at
that if you sell anything throw it I
definitely Crank It Up yeah let's just
lean into it but I'm not gonna go all
the way back to baby step two intensity
no I don't think I'd be beans and rice
but I definitely wouldn't lollygag it
like it wouldn't be a walk in the park
four years is Max in my mind yeah
so okay well that that's good I I mean
does your advice change at all if um
I have nine kids
[Music]
not really I mean if you the margins the
margin
well I mean it it may mean that you
can't put 55 towards it it may take
longer than four years but I'm still
going to have an emergency fund in place
I'm still going to put 15 aside and I'm
still going to scratch around in the
budget and throw as much of it as I can
towards this
um the only other option is to refinance
and the problem is your first mortgage
is so low and it's bigger that the mat
the weighted average of the two interest
rates is on a current interest rate of
seven or so it's going to be much higher
so I would not refinance it uh unless
you just had to to keep from losing the
house or something you're not at that
stage
um but the faster you get rid of this
thing hanging around your neck as you've
already come to realize the faster
you're going to have prosperity and
peace in the family and so you know I'm
going to lean into it as hard as I can I
don't know what your schedule is with a
three was it nine kids and activities
and what all you've got plugged in there
and what all is built into that budget
but people with large families do the
stuff we talk about all the time but
sometimes it just means it takes longer
and you may take you longer than four
years if you had two kids or no kids or
something you could do it in four years
without it there's no question fifty
thousand five thousand out of 231
a year is just doable okay I agree throw
in nine kids and 15 going to retirement
yeah it might be hard get tight might be
hard you might have to take five years
but I I really don't want you to drag
this thing out I'm with you Jade in that
sense I want to have some
urgency and you already had that urgency
before you called us so all we're doing
is agreeing with what you're already
thinking in that sense so good question
Johnny is in Cincinnati hey Johnny
welcome to the Ramsay show
hey guys thank you I I have tried to get
on the show so long ago I have
resurfaced it thank you this is this is
Monumental for me because I need the
help we'll try how can we help my wife
and I I'll get your get your notebooks
out this is gonna be good I I oh I can't
wait
um to my wife we have been like five
years I'm 43 years old she's 46. little
late bloomers
um got a three-year-old I bought in your
system way back when and I changed my
life
I didn't know I was going to get married
didn't know I was going to have a kid it
happened in my 40s
everything's awesome but my wife it's
hard getting her on the program so
here's what's happened
I had my ducks in a row before we got
married I'm living the Snowball Effect
I'm almost set free and paying this
house off and y'all didn't talk about it
when we got married 401k
this is before we got married you didn't
talk about it though before you got
married
well well we kind of did
kind of means you didn't I mean I don't
think we established all the boundaries
and stuff we talked about it oh she
didn't understand what all what you were
doing and how important it was to you
you didn't talk about it much kind of
means you didn't there you go
man that's good that's very good that's
perceptive that's that's exactly what's
happened so now we're five in
and she thinks you're crazy now
and getting her on the same page is a
tough ball game how much have you guys
gone back into
okay so I okay we're trying to do the
old school thing yeah we're we're up
against a break and I apologize so
here's what I would tell you you're
trying to work on the details of the
plan rather than the vision of the plan
you need to pan back the conversation
say honey where do we want to be when
we're 65. where do we want to be when
we're 55 what's the best way to get
there I think the plan I've been using
is the best way to get there we can talk
about that but we have to agree on our
Dream in High Definition before we start
working on the tactics you went straight
to tactics and she thinks you lost your
mind that's how you fix this
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the debt
free stage Ryan and Jenny are with us
hey guys how are you good good how are
you better than I deserve where do you
all live Radford Virginia ah welcome to
Nashville good to have you and how much
debt have you paid off
290k all right how long did this take
six years and about 10 months good for
you and what was your ad what was your
high income and your low income during
that time high income probably about 170
um low income about 55. wow what do you
all do for a living
I work with the public so do you work
with the public yes yeah we all do
like in PR what do you mean
um
like investment stuff cool okay all
right and what do you do I'm a program
manager okay very cool good to have you
guys and so 290 over six years I'm
guessing you paid off your house that's
right yes very cool looking at weird
people love it congratulations what's
this house worth uh when we bought it
probably about 205 and whatever the
market is now right so what would you
think it is now probably 3 20. okay good
for y'all way to go how old are you two
I'm 31. I'm 32. yeah pay four house in
freaking Virginia that's right I mean
that's incredible way to go thank you
how's that feel awesome it feels good
for our kids that are here today and
um we're excited to really stack some
money away from them good for your
parents they know you're not moving back
to their basement that's right that's
true so I mean everybody's happy right
that's right the way to go you guys
pretty incredible 55 to 170 nice income
jump during that time I'm guessing one
of the careers must have kicked off
during that that doubled the incoming
some almost both yeah yeah okay wow good
for y'all well done very well done hey
man that's powerful all right tell us
the story what started this journey
um I actually heard your name while I
was working at a bank
um my first job out of college didn't
know who you were never heard of you so
I was like well I'll look this guy up
everybody was talking about you at the
training I guess that's not what's that
good or bad Bank training and my name
comes up I think we know what that was
it was like the devil they were talking
great about you and I was like well I'll
look into it I have some student loans
and so does my soon-to-be wife so we'll
look into it and I think you bought me
the book for Christmas yep I read it and
game was over there it is yes history
just like that and so Jenny you brought
the book so you you kind of go look go
along with it then right oh yeah oh yeah
it was I was your really your idea yeah
it was my idea yeah that's cool so
you're here you're
at student loans too how much did you
pay off it's about 80k in student loans
people are doing it every day love it
good for you guys
so what do you tell people you use The
Total Money Makeover book and what else
how else did you plug into us uh we
actually went to the bank every two
weeks and got certain denominations of
bills and put them in envelopes and we
used a lot of envelopes because those
envelopes got wore out
um we still maybe went to Target and
walked around but we didn't buy anything
for a couple years she still had to get
her fix on that yeah
but yeah I mean it's really just being
intentional with it as you always preach
and if you're intentional with it you
know it'll happen it was hard along the
way because you
you know you don't see a whole lot of
progress every day but you know when you
pay one off you really start seeing it
grow so that's something
some of your friends make fun of you
um they laughed at the envelopes for
sure so we upgraded to the wallet
eventually but we wore that thing out
too yeah oh very good you know and now
you're kind of in a position like uh
live in a 300 and something thousand
dollar house it's paid for wow that's
right and I'm 30 years old how you like
me now right that's right exactly how
you like my envelopes now that's right
yeah I like it so you've got this whole
village of people over here next to you
who's the Posse yeah so we have my
family here her family wasn't able to
make it um but they're listening in
um but we have my brother my
sister-in-law my great my grandmother my
grandfather my mom and dad and then our
two kids ah well they all got to be
proud yeah very cool good for you guys
well done well done all right so
somebody's listening for the first time
today they've never heard of all this
Ramsey stuff you read The Total Money
Makeover book and that was it game on
you went through just the book and you
said I'm gonna do this and here we are
six years later you're standing on this
stage paid off your house and everything
what is the key to getting out of debt
in your own minds
consistency just stay consistent and be
disciplined just continue you'll see the
payoff eventually
boring isn't it it is but it's okay
I love that love it what about you Ryan
what do you think
um you know just like she said you can't
really see the end of the road but you
can always see what the headlights show
you on the road so you know just stay
with the journey and eventually you end
up where you need to go it is a long
journey but eventually you get there so
you guys got there that's great so
what's uh how much is in your house
401ks and Roth IRAs and stuff um we
probably have about a quarter million in
in there and starting to stack even more
and more in in some mutual funds and
things so so you're about a halfway to
millionaire already and you're only 31.
that's right way to go you gosh you'll
be baby steps millionaires before we
know it Easy by 35 easy the way you're
going way to go you guys I'm very proud
of y'all I know your whole family is
they wouldn't have come to support you
otherwise unless they just want an
excuse to come to Nashville and party I
don't know what it was it could have
could have been that but yeah but
they're proud of you too congratulations
you guys very well done and you brought
the kiddos bring them up what are their
names and ages so we have Luke and he's
six months oh wow and Tegan and she's
two cute wow beautiful beautiful family
well done well those kids don't even
know how great a Heroes their parents
are completely changed your family tree
the math that goes from here is millions
and millions it's going to be amazing
where you all are going to be if you
just stay the course and just be smart I
mean just be wise which the culture is
so crazy but you guys have the ability
to end up with an amazing wealth that
you built for these two and way to go
very very proud of y'all hey we've got
the live and give box for you that
includes the baby steps millionaires
book your next stop and The Total Money
Makeover book those are both number one
bestsellers showing folks how to do it
you started with The Total Money
Makeover you'll be able to give that
away to somebody and help them in the
Financial Peace University membership as
well if you haven't been through it go
through it if you have then give it to
somebody it's the live and give box
proud of you guys well done well done
Ryan and Jenny teakin and Luke from
Virginia 290 000 paid off in six years
in 10 months making 55 to 1 170 31 years
old debt free house and everything
they're weirdos I love it count it down
let's hear a dead tree scream ready
three three two one
[Applause]
wow wow
that's amazing
it's amazing literally textbook Dave
textbook exactly and the math goes I
mean it guys just put in a financial
calculator
what a two thousand dollar house payment
becomes in 10 years when you pay it into
mutual funds in your 401K Roth and just
see how much money that is it's millions
of dollars they're gonna have buku bucks
yep 100 gonna be they're set up for life
and those little that little bitty cute
baby is in great shape I just need
people to hear this and see this 80 000
in student loan debt that they paid off
I mean they're making between 55 to 170k
so I got to believe that for most of
that time they're maybe around 100 right
because it's not to say they were making
170 all six almost seven years right
right paid off 80 000 in student loan
went on to pay off their home in the
amount of time that we say between seven
to ten years is usually what it takes
there it's real is what I want people to
it's real this is not just a few people
get it or a few people like every day we
see these people doing what Ryan and
Ginny did they're inspiring their Heroes
it's inspiring man they're Heroes they
change their whole life they change
their whole family tree by paying a
price to win that's right and uh you
know the thing is you can just decide
they did yeah you I'm talking to you
right along the interstate right now you
you can just decide right now you're no
different yep you yes you
you the shot right
now
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
so we fix our eyes not what is on what
is seen but what is unseen since what is
seen is temporary but what is unseen is
eternal
Linda said I've trained my whole life
not to be distracted by distractions
the great wallinda you gotta love it
Tori is with us Tori is in Providence
Rhode Island hi Tori what's up
hi thank you for taking my call sure
um Dave you mentioned middle class
stupid things earlier and well my
husband and I bought too much house
yes
I'll give you a quick story so you
always say to only take out a 15-year
fixed mortgage or the payment no more
than 25 of your take-home pay uh we got
foolish and we bought a house for 425
thousand dollars our total monthly
payment is about 25 of our 10 000
take-home pay but we're on a 30-year
fixed
um we use the mortgage payoff calculator
on the Ramsey Solutions website and it
says if we put a thousand extra each
month we could knock this out in 15
years but then of course we're putting
more than 35 percent of our take-home
pay towards the house so my question is
what would you do to tackle this if you
woke up in my shoes what is the Curve
prediction on your household income
I mean like what what are your what are
your careers and how fast do you see
your incomes coming up
we're 39 years old I feel like my
husband is uh probably he's already kind
of at the top of concealed uh in library
services around 105k I'm at 67k and
I I don't know how to answer that
question
was on today what do you do you know I
work in I work in higher education
Administration so just sticking straight
off work
okay
all right so the chances of you all
raising your income
in the next three or four years
to make this a 25 is fairly low
I think so but I mean maybe I'm being
pessimistic okay
[Music]
hmm
what else do you own
uh really uh nothing I mean we are we
are debt free we have the emergency fund
and then aside from emergency funding
retirement we have about sixty thousand
dollars in a sinking fund uh earmarked
for just home repairs I actually thought
a relatively old house and then we have
a hundred and five thousand dollars in
taxable taxable brokerage account
what do you owe in the house
uh let's see we put 15 down so we owe
360k
and you have a hundred and sixty
thousand dollars
correct
what's your interest rate on your
mortgage
5.5
okay
um
I think if you pay your regular payment
and put 160 000 of your liquid cash
towards your mortgage you'll be done in
15 years
yep okay
I think yeah I think you could run that
math out
yeah absolutely and we're we budget we
budget a zero-based budget so we know we
can for sure throw a thousand extra give
me the numbers again what's your balance
on the mortgage
yeah 360 balance on the mortgage 369 and
you got you you have 60 in a sinking
fund and what was the other non the
other taxable account
105k 105 so 165. okay so let's just say
300K at your current payment
no I'm sorry excuse me uh 200k at your
current payment that'll pay off in less
than 15 years
okay yep yep well you still have no but
the payment is still a 35 of your
take-home pay or still yeah no it's not
because you're on the 30. we turned your
30 into a 15 by reducing the principal
if you want to keep the house put all
this money on the balance
okay so just drain drain the whole thing
yeah I mean down to it you need to keep
an emergency fund of three to six months
of expenses
but any repairs or upgrades you're going
to do you're going to do with cash flow
while you pay this house payment
okay because I think we just turned your
30 into a 15 by reducing the balance
I'm doing this in my head so I might not
be right but I'm pretty close
I think you're about right too okay okay
yeah that so that's what bails you out
here now of course the other thing you
can do is not keep the house but that's
the thing is I
a lot of things you do in finances you
just undo them if they're stupid the
house is the most expensive thing to
undo
emotionally because you gotta it's like
having a root canal to move you know you
got you know uh that you're uprooting
everybody you gotta you know the time it
takes to reset all your addresses on
everything oh my gosh and it's expensive
to move it's expensive to move I mean
this is a so if you like the house
enough
to emotionally part with 165
000 and throw that at the balance that
turns you into a good position so if you
had put that much down you would have
been able to take out a 15-year
mm-hmm yep you're right so that's the
only it wasn't the house that was wrong
it was the down payment that was wrong
assuming you like the house and I'm
guessing you love the house because you
were stretching into it yeah that's a
really good way that you put that the
down payment was wrong they put they
threw their money into the wrong thing
yeah they held back to do the route to
do they they got a bunch of Renovations
and stars in their eyes on the house so
they're going to be living in a house
they don't like as much as they would
have had they use that sinking fund
that's right that's right but
um but that sinking fund is what should
have been on the down payment all along
and the 105 and non-intaxable there's no
question yeah so yeah the house wasn't
the wrong purchase I don't know that I'm
trying to think I don't know I've ever
taken that call no that was a very
interesting call that you can reduce the
house
uh amortization and again I'm doing that
in my head I wish I had my wish I had my
financial calculator in front of me see
if that actually worked out but that'd
be very it's very I bet you 200 000 on
that it was five percent two hundred
thousand
um we well the payment we know what the
payment would be we could back into it
at 30. that'd be interesting to do I
wish I had time to do it oh well in the
old days when I first started this radio
show we would sit and do crap like that
live on the air with the calculator and
it was so boring so we'll move on
thank you Dave on behalf of all of us
Jennifer is in Albany New York hey
Jennifer what's up
hi I was calling to see my husband and I
just recently started your baby step s
in July and we've been able to pay off
about eight thousand dollars in debt way
to go I yeah it's been good we we're
doing well but I want to sell my car
what do you owe on it I have a
I owe thirty thousand what's your
household
um 160 to 170 000. what's the other car
worth
um I'm not sure what it's worth roughly
down to the last eight payments roughly
what's it worth
sort of 50 000 car or a twenty thousand
dollar car
oh it's a Ford
SD
um 2008 so maybe the book on it is
somewhere between fifteen thousand and
twenty thousand yeah okay so you got
fifty thousand dollars worth of cars
and you make 160. so the first thing is
you don't want more than half your
annual income in cars you don't violate
that one the second thing is can you pay
off this car and all other Consumer Debt
if you guys keep on this new excitement
that you've got in less than two years
yes if you like the car I would keep it
okay
all right because it's not out of
control to do an add it to the snowball
yeah put it on the debt snowball maybe
the bottom of that snowball if you don't
want to keep it it's okay to sell it but
our rule of thumb is if it's it's a boat
anchor in the math and it's going to
take you longer than two years or the
total of your cars is like right 80 of
your household income and you got too
much tied up and things going down in
value then you would need to sell it but
you don't violate either one of those
math guidelines so then it just comes
down to a choice if you the two of you
want to sell it nothing wrong with
selling it but is it necessary for you
to succeed financially for you to sell
this car no no it just depends
do you want to go yeah you want to go
faster than which is kind of she's got
the new excitement yeah I'll tell you
what why do Christmas
it's after Christmas after after the
first of the year y'all talk about it
again let the let the newness wear off
of the excitement of the attack Zone
because it's gonna it's gonna start to
yeah the gazelle gets tired when he's
intense
he's running fast that's it
that puts this hour the Ramsey showing
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]